hey guys Ryan right here and Jerry as
well we're gonna watch the trailer and
we're going to give you a heads up Jerry
has already seen the trailer a couple
times oh yeah but he is very excited
about it which gets right over here very
exciting so why rye bread like rye bread
yeah right right right bread the real
right right it's like yeah real right
right yeah yeah yeah chappy is a sex
position no it's not there's another
[ __ ] this is thinking the distinct
idea
[Music]
I brought you into this world a machine
that can think and feel
[Music]
Oh reject that's a one
- the lobe
anything you want to do in your life in
the right poetry have dimensional ideas
[Music]
people are always fearful of something
they don't understand
problem without official intelligence is
a slight so I'm pretty too
you know what's a black sheep
it's like when you different to everyone
else
[Music]
he told us so much bull I can ever
imagine
you're gonna make you cool a tough
longer something to serve up who's gonna
be moved kid they could be the next step
in the evolution
and interest this
[Music]
cool it looks awesome
yeah who's that directory did neill
blomkamp yeah he is [ __ ] awesome dude
oh man when he went back to like to do
an indie movie like to do an indie scale
in South Africa for this it's kind of
like his version of wall-e he described
it as being like et meets Robocop and
with yes and with you that is exactly
what it looks like yeah
et meets Robocop that's great I mean
this movie is partly notable too because
I don't know if you know who die
Antwoord is but there are South African
rap duo okay and they're the two people
that find him and raise him like that's
the blonde girl and the dude who's like
walking around the shorts teaching
that'd be cool no one seemed like that's
who they huh oh sweet so you got like
their their big sensation now who plays
chappie shelter Copley oh really he did
the mocap and the voice yeah no way oh
do that guy's fantastic him and Neal
block him know how to work together
really well with they were they really
understand each other and I already love
chappie
like I love chappies like I want I want
you to be real and he looks real big ol
hug the effects on them are fantastic it
like looks it looks real
feels real I like the idea of seeing the
human world through machines eyes like
truly seeing it like that but I make him
as almost like as a child you know and I
think that exactly that that was the
really relatable link to it is like
they're raising a child like they have
to start him off with cartoons did he
now yeah that's pretty neat yeah there's
a lot of neat stuff about this well he's
always got I think he's got really cool
ideas and always really cool designs and
he knows how to make you know that sort
of lo-fi sci-fi world he knows how to
make movies that have incredible visuals
but the same time if you pay attention
there for the most part very grounded
tales you know like this turbine doesn't
take place in a huge place you know like
there's a lot of characters but it's not
it's one small part you know what it
feels more real that way because it's
it's in a very familiar setting with one
or
- you know futuristic elements exactly
exactly you know and I mean I really
like Elysium but I think that movie you
know suffers from some sort of big
Hollywood pitfalls yeah glad to see him
back in his element you know cuz after
that movie I think he sort of said like
I've done my big Syria thing I want to
go back to you know being on a more
limited scale it's cool because this
looks like his most technically
realistic film like more possible to
fathom film yeah you know not aliens and
it's not money stay traveling to another
yeah a Space Station we're good all of
these living stuff it's this one robot
of the beginning the start of the yeah
because they freaked out about the fact
that they have a robot you know so must
be like the first robot for the first
you know artificial intelligence you
know and Hugh Jackman's doing his
Wolverine prisoners thing where he's
really intense there's something about
when people let actor just use their
natural acts and when you don't ever
hear it mm-hmm he just seems like and it
doesn't seem like the typical kind of
Hugh Jackman role so I was like that's
cool you know it's like he's here
doing this role and you know just in his
natural accident you know it's like it's
a very unglamorous what's cool about him
is like he looks like he's technically
them I guess you would say the
antagonist or the antagonist of the film
but at least he's going to be an
antagonist who really believes is in the
right yeah it looks like a
straightforward but honest performance
yeah exactly
at least from the few corpses lay
Jackman is a great actor you know it's
like playa people mainly just doom for
Wolverine but yeah he's had some other
roles too that are pretty damn good
pretty good swordfish got his dick
sucked all figured out that password
that's what I remember I remember that
yeah yeah are being very young and going
what's happening will over in right now
pretty crazy anyway guys thanks for
recommending that trailer if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects recently partnered with
awesome company fullscreen as is true
thank you
which has the likes of many other famous
youtubers here's a list I was too lazy
to actually come up with a list and Oh
Jerry
has a playlist I do I love reasons to
Jerry him in his car it's awesome keep a
look out for it is inter super stellar
review oh yeah and if you want to keep
the robot game going check out the
trailer for ex machina machina yeah
machina like x might light not like Deus
Ex mode yeah I know exactly were talking
Daniel Aguilar let me get that shout out
Daniel Aguilar is a your during the
drive-thru yeah he thinks this is a
drive to get that uh a shout-out let me
get a number 6 January Aguilar is
actually the son of Christina Aguilera
who's that no one cuz I was thinking of
Christina Aguilera you are no one is
there you are no one has messed up
though he's one of her fans just dismiss
his existence fan yeah you're a good guy
punks von Dell please shout out me the
real rejects
pugs von Dell hummus mondo that is a
they're actually a group of German
gangsters okay I'll go along with you on
that yeah they they go around and they
do horrible crimes they jaywalk they
litter the urinate on walls when people
are not walking by but no it's so messed
up and I messed up
they have gotten many tickets in their
life oh boy
yeah never going to jail surprisingly a
man that prized are so infamous for the
amount of cigarette butts that you find
on the street from them never been to
jail oh yeah they're there they're in
town mm-hmm you find cigarette butts
next to pee you know what happened and
they also they do a lot of contraband to
heroin specifically heroin Oh Harold so
they do have one legitimately sinister
yeah but no one really talks about it